good morning millennials
welcome back to the toast happy Tuesday
everyone it is so great to be back after
a really gorgeous bank holiday thank you
Banks thank you presidents thank you Jax
hey Jax
welcome to the show thank you so much
for being here
thank you for having me 30 on my own
show for giving me the space to say
hello to everyone hope everyone had an
amazing president's weekend it was so
glorious to have that weekend to hold
that weekend to hold to having to hold I
had an amazing weekend thanks for asking
my staycation was such a success and I'm
so glad that something that we said on
the show inspired me to book it I don't
know what it was we're so inspirational
we're constantly inspiring people
including ourselves yourself
um yeah it was a gorgeous three-day
weekend I have to say
um
I've always really believed in the
three-day weekend four-day work week but
to experience it and see what life could
be like you know every week for the
ratio of four to three versus the crazy
ratio we currently have a five to two
I'm even more inspired and more
motivated to restart my campaign for the
four day work week but turdy
it wouldn't be special if we had it
every week and then you'd start
campaigning for five and two on the
other I wouldn't I wouldn't
I wouldn't
maybe centuries ago it was a six in one
and they were like if we only had five
and two we would be so happy we'd be so
rested and now look at us asking for
four and three well that means we're
heading in the right direction that one
day we'll be 7-0 and that's the dream
isn't it
be careful what you wish for attorney
okay all I'm saying is the four-day work
week is a proven concept and I
experienced it it was incredible and I
know what you guys are gonna say like
you know we do run our own business it's
up to the businesses like you could make
yourself a four but it wouldn't feel
like a three-day weekend if not everyone
had it so I needed to be like a federal
thing and I think it's best as a sweet
treat
of course you do because you're
literally like turning into the teacher
we all hated and that's right
you prefer to be called gen Z's big
sister
yeah okay keep talking like that they're
gonna call you gen Z's arch nemesis no
gen Z we see each other you wouldn't
understand because you're just kind of
like untethered to a generation
not you coming for my [__] neck
[__] coming from I know I know how much
that hurts you when you're told that
you're not a part of gen Z
like you know I am and I think it's so
important for me to you know just humble
you right now like first of all I don't
even know like where you got the name
genzy's big sister like I don't think
anyone even calls you that um check out
I want check out my I want my dinner
now's Instagram bio
well let me tell you check it out that
the reason
maybe one person has said that is
because of the influence you have on
Tick Tock created by me so so you
invented your mouth watch your
[__] mouth you invented me I
literally created the Gen Z Persona that
you just kind of LARP
well why can't you do it for yourself
then if you're so good at it I have I
have and who are you I have who are you
to them
I am gen Z's Queen okay
Quinn
Angela Bassett did the thing ugh I'm so
excited that this morning there's a
really interesting array of stories but
one story that it's captured my heart
yeah in the 11th hour I didn't know
about it until I woke up this morning
and I actually had like a lot of time to
pick stories this morning so I just did
like a deep dive on the tweets about
Ariana dubose's bafta's opening
monologue song rap
um
and it was really something special to
see we're going to talk about it we
actually got a big show because not only
do we have good stories especially we
have a big show because there was no
show yesterday we have a lot to catch up
on we also are going to do a major TV
recap because over the weekend Jackie
and I both watched summer house I am all
caught up on Real Housewives of New
Jersey I am all caught up on Vanderpump
Rules oh good I haven't been watching
and um your girl cloudy McClure and
mcturd finally watched dope sick after
Jackie like basically calling that I
would watch it and I really thought I
wasn't gonna but over the weekend you
know me and Ben were looking for
something we ate that [__] up it was so
good so we're gonna do like a big deal
you can get your domestic recap now are
you sure yeah because that's like
different from TV recap this is just
like culture recap I mean it was an
amazing show
I wish it never had to be made you know
it was so upsetting and I've never been
one to you know Lobby against big Pharma
like when people were talking about big
Pharma I was like okay I literally
didn't even know what they were talking
about I'm like yeah big Pharma I was
like I never knew if like big Pharma was
good or bad like I didn't even know what
people were talking about but I know
like it's a thing the way if I ever see
Richard Sackler in these streets I'm
literally gonna stab him like I am so
involved now I think I'm gonna go Lobby
against big Pharma like
wow that's all I'll say my my eyes were
opened this I had obviously heard of
like you know the West Virginia area you
know Appalachia they have a reputation
for just kind of you know being full of
drug addicts and it's like well why why
and to learn how it all got started with
these just truly evil demonic people not
just one obviously the sacklers but so
many people made the opioid crisis
possible was so upsetting and it's so
many takeaways from the show the first
being that that young actress who plays
Betsy who was also in book smart what's
her name
I don't know
because she looks like someone else and
I always just think about that person
that she looks like but let me pull it
up
dope because
she's a star she's I think going to be
one of the great actresses of our time
Caitlin Dever Caitlyn Deborah A lot of
people know I think her breakout role
was you know beanie feldstein's sidekick
in book smart where she was great it was
but then she was also in unbelievable
which you watched yeah oh my God so good
I didn't watch that uh she was in dear
Evan Hansen oh yeah she was in Bad
Teacher and she was she was that little
snot-nosed kid well she was much younger
I was trying to get extra credit
she's incredible like I think she will
be like uh a cape Blanchette of our time
I think she has a very long career ahead
of her I think you mean Blanchette Kate
yeah I do mean Blanche Kate thank you um
for correcting me she's incredible she
was amazing me and I cried so many times
during the show Michael Keaton was
incredible Peter Skarsgard showed up
like everyone it was so good it was so
upsetting
oh
it's honestly I don't even know what
else to say it was it was I was deeply
troubled and deeply moved by the whole
the whole show and I know a lot of the
characters in that story like they
themselves did not exist
um but their stories are like
amalgamation they're like composite
characters and apparently the Michael
Keaton character like is a is a real guy
because it's based on a book
so there was a doctor who was like
heavily addicted I think he was taking
like 100 pills a day at one point
prescribed heavily prescribing oxy and
like I don't think he started as like
this evil person no the doctor becoming
an addict was something I so did not see
coming and the second his car got hit I
was like oh
I thought that the uh the district
attorney when he had the surgery for
cancer I thought he was going to get
addicted like I know it was it was so
good I thought it really highlighted
like not only the opioid crisis but just
like how damaging addiction can be for
like people's families and not just the
person but it's like for every one
person that's touched by addiction
there's like 50 other people who they're
you know related to who they'll never
touched by it yeah um I thought the
actress who played the mom was
incredible oh my God she made me cry
when like they when they opened the
final episode with like all the protests
that we're taking
um place like 10 years later like it's
so crazy how literally the show started
in 1998 and nothing actually really
happened majorly in the culture until
2019. I was like this is [__]
um
when she was at the Guggenheim
protesting for her daughter like I was
just I was sobbing I was obsessed with
her it was it was so good you were right
I'm a big dope we know this
reading dope like I'm a dope
um it was incredible and I I cannot
recommend it enough I completely agree
I'm so glad that you feel that way and
Ben liked it too loved oh my God and you
know he was just happy because usually
we'll start a show together and then
I'll finish it like when he's out
golfing and he'll never he'd never
finish uh House of the Dragon he never
finished uh so many I don't think you've
ever watched a Game of Thrones finale
like so many good episodes like he just
never finishes stuff so I think he was
also just really excited to like finally
see something through to be a part of
something with you yeah and I relate to
that well next you guys have to watch
Chernobyl yeah that's next on our list
you absolutely have to also because it's
very relevant to what's going on right
now in the country like what we're
experiencing well what's happening in
like East Palestine Ohio is perhaps one
of the biggest environmental disasters
in our country's history and it's kind
of like not being talked about and
they're definitely not getting the help
that they need it's it's like really
[__] weird it's so crazy and not that
it's important at all but like it being
called Palestine Palestine like who knew
there was a place in America with that
name like I was when people were talking
about I was like oh great like more you
know trouble in the Middle East and then
honestly I don't even think I read a
bunch of the headlines because I was
like honestly I can't like I can't it's
such a it's such a troubling region like
I need to protect my my mental health
um and then
but someone was like it's in Ohio I'm
like excuse me it's like Paris Texas
it's just honestly I know that has
nothing like there's so much going on
and I hate to like but I was shook
honestly yeah um but it's also
pronounced Palestine there yeah yeah no
I know so but it's spelled the same so
when you're reading headlines you don't
know it's no the first time I saw it I
was like what is this chemical exposure
in Ohio have anything to do with what's
going on
like apples and oranges and then I
understood and I was like oh okay yeah
no it's really sad so sending lots of
love to all of our Ohio toasters and
people affected in the region not just
Ohio no and it's like a lot of people
are going to be affected in the region
that's the whole point of like right
water we need to clean it up the water
the Farms the animals the people the air
like it's terrible terrible terrible
terrible
um so yes Chernobyl is quite relevant
that is next on my list
um but all in all it was an eye-opening
weekend watching dope sick like big
Pharma I've got my eye on you yeah
love that for you keeping one eye open
for a big Pharma I'm keeping an eye out
and you know Purdue is like still like
you know
there's still like a company yeah but I
feel like I don't when you think about
like the big names in farm Pfizer
moderna you know they're AstraZeneca I
feel like their time has passed you know
no and I hope you know that was a lesson
to all
in the form of space I no wait it was
not and they still they still like to
are they still pull the same [__] like
those pain charts are still in every
hospital like am I a two-year-old can I
just tell you I'm in pain I don't have
to rate it on a scale with the angry
face
hundred percent and for me what was so
crazy was you know they were visiting
doctors in jail who had over prescribed
medication and it's like okay so these
doctors are in jail but like nobody who
created the medication is right and the
people who were like pushing it and
selling to the doctors and the doctor
was like
are trying to do their job and help
people they didn't seek out harm no no
no no no totally it was just it was
really but the doctors trust the FDA and
they trust these organizations that are
put in place to make sure that we have
like a functioning Health Care System
let me tell you thank you for bringing
up the [__] at the FDA I'm
keeping an eye out for them too and if I
ever see Curtis Wilson on the street
it's [__] over for him
like I'm pissed yeah that's where I
think like
the biggest disappointment lies because
like those agencies are are put in place
to like protect people keep people
healthy keep people safe and to look out
for like the big bad Pharma people and
to protect the average person I find
that more often than not when I watch
documentaries about like major scandals
or Major Crimes more often than not like
there was a a federal agency involved
and and and contacted and never not once
does that job does that uh agency
actually do their job whether it's Child
Services whether it's the FDA whether
it's the Department of Health like
they're always like on there's always
like a paper trail oh yeah they knew
about this in 1992 and they never do
anything so you know what this is what I
have to say to the government
[__]
yeah in case you're listening as a
podcast I'm holding up both my fingers
the middle ones the middle ones
so it was eye-opening thanks Jax for
opening my eyes to all the corruption it
was it was [__] depressing and it was
the way I watched film there was
something about it that just like sucks
you in no and it was it's one of those
shows like I try to stay away from
because it really does like affect your
mental health it's it's so sad but you
can't ignore reality no you can and that
um
that guy he I think his name is John
Brown he was the
the district attorney not the assistants
who like did all the research but the
guy who like the older guy took the ball
all the way down the field who like
really rallied for them like what a guy
was just like no intent on Making Waves
no let's also talk about that scene
where they get called to the Attorney
General's office I believe his name is
James Comey and they think it's about
Purdue chicken was that real
it had to have been because
that's insane to make up
and then like all the people in
government who were like blocking the
the indictment what the [__] are we
[__] voting for these [__] morons
for like do your [__] job [__]
why are you gonna become a politician
just to be an ass wipe okay everyone
because they get everyone they get the
money for their campaign from the
pharmaceutical companies they couldn't
have won without that money and then
when they get into office it becomes
their job to grease the wheels and make
it easier for them that's what I've
learned you know and I knew that but to
really see it played out people in
government people in politics are so
[__] unscrupled literal little
shits I hate them all yeah every single
one
damn yeah so that's my job sick recap we
have more TV recap at the end of the
show oh Bravo teams Bravo Tings I also
watched American Idol on Sunday because
like why the [__] not such a good show I
know like nobody actually comes from
there anymore except maybe Gabby Barrett
but I I had heard she was like you know
tied to Luke Bryan prior so she was
always going to be a star
um
and it's really just like a talent show
and it's fun to watch and it's really so
good I don't know why they like the
people who sit down to edit the footage
are like okay how can we make America
cry like they're just they oh someone
comes in oh you have a good singing
voice tell me about your childhood
trauma like they have to LARP on that
harp on that
um but it was so good me and men were
sobbing that guy from Hawaii oh my God
and then the guy who's saying Billy Joel
if you watched so good that's emotional
it's so emotional I remember as a kid
they were always making us cry too yeah
like why
you get more invested in the people in
their journey and it just means more
when you know something about them yeah
I mean I can't talk about crying on
American Idol without talking about
piece by piece you know no you couldn't
you can have a list of my my favorite
stories as well Kelly Clarkson nine
months pregnant singing piece by piece a
really beautiful song about her father
abandoning her
um performing it you know
for the umpteenth time it wasn't the
first time she performed it but
something about being back at American
Idol and performing on that stage and
being pregnant she sobbed through the
whole thing and Keith Urban's sitting
there sobbing Harry Connick Jr JLo it's
a beautiful moment I could watch that
clip and I do on a weekly basis it comes
up on my Tick Tock at least once a week
I love that for you but then you're
crying once a week
um that's the case I think usually you
know I'm sorry turdy
so I mean like I'm always seeing [__]
online that's making me cry military
reunions oh asking my stepdad to adopt
me oh my God those ones really [__]
get me children hearing for the first
children seeing for the first time oh my
God those ones really [__] get to me
always tag me in those oh man have you
seen the one of the girl and the man who
are getting married and he turns around
for like the big reveal and she gives
him a present and it's those really
expensive glasses if you're colorblind
you can wear them and you can see
normally and she hands him to him and
he's like oh my God you got me these
like they're so and and he puts them on
and they're standing outside in this
like beautiful hilled like lavender
field and he just looks at her and he
looks around he's like oh my God you
guys see this every day I'm gonna
literally gonna start crying talking
about it and he's like you look so
beautiful it's literally I I see it all
the time it's one of my most favorite
viral videos never seen it um it hasn't
made it to Reels oh yeah you got to see
it I'll send it to you next time it
comes across my my desk damn
I love viral [__] like that oh my God
it's nice
dirty that's beautiful
it is and what else is beautiful the
toast and that's the the best you're
gonna get for me in terms of the Segway
today yes so I think without further Ado
oh no
no big announcement big announcement
it's that time of the month y'all today
well it is that time of the month I do
have my period
um but today is also uh a gorgeous day
because Jackie and I today at 5 PM
eastern time are going to do another
episode of freaking Fred so it is our
YouTube live episode that we do was
trying to do once a month for our so far
we're on track we're two for two [__]
well let's see how tonight goes no we'll
still do it guys out don't jinx it
oh my God okay like
sure not you being negative
um our YouTube live episodes we do uh
once a month they're really fun we play
lots of games people can tune in live
you can join the chat it's really fun if
you guys remember we used to do an audio
version on Spotify live now we're doing
video and audio on YouTube live so you
have to be patreon member to gain access
it's 5 PM eastern time if you're not a
patreon member that's totally fine you
have until like 4 55 tonight to become a
patreon member the link will be in
patreon you can join live if you can't
join live you still can watch it uh
later on it'll be about an hour and it's
super fun it's just like an evening with
your girlies you know you can cocktail
it up an evening with Jackson turd
an evening with Jackson turd so I'm
excited for that me too but before we do
that we have to do this yeah which is
the fast five stories that you need to
know
period period period like that's it yeah
no that's it that's why you need to know
oh and the three TV Recaps you should
know as well
and it's a three TV Recaps and fast five
stories that you need to know that are
brought to you by liquid IV if you're
trying to improve your health hydration
is a great place to start and liquidity
is the hydration brand that fuels your
well-being by the way liquid Ivy came in
clutch for me this weekend I went out
hard on Friday
yeah and when I got home I chugged a
liquid IV before bed and when I woke up
and I had one and it made an enormous
difference it's just like it I use it
for hangovers and hydration but you know
a little life hack for hangovers
um so the hydration multiplier from
liquid IV is one of the products that
you are missing out in your daily
routine in just one stick you'll get
five essential vitamins and two times
faster hydration than just water alone
use it first thing in the morning before
a workout when you're feeling run down
after a long night out on a long flight
there's so many times where like your
overall Wellness is just like not it
because you're probably dehydrated
you're having like a deficiency of some
sort and drinking water with liquid IV
is just gonna make that water do more
for you get your vitamins get your
hydration so in the Stick of liquid IV
pour it into 16 ounces of water and
you're going to to get vitamin B3 B5 B6
B12 vitamin C you'll have three times
the electrolytes of a traditional sports
drink it has premium ingredients it's
non-GMO it's free from gluten dairy and
soy and it's going to hydrate you two
times faster and more efficiently than
water alone liquid IV is also a great
brand to support because they're on a
mission to change the world to date
liquidity has donated over 36 million
servings in over 50 countries around the
world liquid IV is just something you
always need to have in your house
because when you need it and you don't
have it you'll be kicking yourself I
have like three different flavors they
have really good flavors too they're all
really good just keep a couple tubes in
your purse in your office desk if you
show up hungover to work you had a
migraine just make sure to always have
it on you okay you can grab your liquid
IV in bulk nationwide at Costco or you
can get 20 off when you go to
liquidity.com use code toast at checkout
that's 20 off anything you order when
you shop better hydration today using
promo code toast at liquid ivy.com
thank you turdy you're welcome our first
story
in defense of Ariana dubose's rap bafta
producer slams Twitter Twitter criticism
as incredibly unfair claims everybody
loved it
back does awards producer Nick Bowen
believes Twitter's criticism of Ariana
dubose's opening number at Sunday's
award show was incredibly unfair so the
Baptist took place this weekend Ariana
Dubose opened the show with a musical
number that uh first she belted out
sisters are doing it for themselves We
are family and she transitioned into an
original rap that saluted the awards
female nominees now
um no description of it will do it
justice you should watch it for yourself
you just it's something you have to see
and but I do have a transcription of the
rap lyrics so do I Angela Bassett did
the thing Biola Davis my woman King
Blanchette Kate your Genius Jamie Lee
you are all of us no she went like this
Jamie Lee you are all of us yeah oh uh
that's all they gave me there was more
there was more she basically called uh
like uh added to Arms you wear gray and
blonde yeah like she no she's shouted
out all of the female nominees and yeah
there's more that began but like it's
that Angela Bassett did the thing part
that really has people in a tizzy yeah
for me the first time I saw it I when I
first watched it I didn't know if it was
going viral because it was good or bad
so I was watching it thinking it was
good and like it was because like Liz
hype posted it like without comments she
was like this is going viral for obvious
reasons and I was like oh because she
like what are the reasons I I thought it
was because like she hosted the Baptist
like she gave it her all she's saying
she danced she wrapped and I'm watching
and I'm like people think this is good
like this is her she's so out of breath
she's out of breath the wrap was
actually like really poorly written like
I thought the Rhymes and like the iambic
pentameter was super awesome like it was
actually bothering me the video I
watched had the lyrics over it but if it
didn't I'm not sure I would have yes who
she was talking about and they panned to
everyone she's talking about as she's
talking about them and they give like a
look they have no idea she started some
of them have no idea she's talking about
them because it's unclear what she said
begging like if she's like running
through it and she's dancing to her
she's doing the most and it's like that
would have been attack she's like
running through the stage it's like that
would have been the time just like focus
on the rap now I want to talk about the
producer who stepped forward oh wait I
wanna I just want to tell you what he
said okay he spoke because honestly I
didn't know this man before and now that
I do know him I just want everyone to
know like how little respect I have for
him he spoke to the variety uh the
morning after The Telecast and shared
that the West Side Story star put the
whole piece together with her team
working closely with the musical
director and choreographer and didn't
deserve the vitriol all right on the
Dubose in her back up dancers burst onto
the stage following host a Richard E
Grant's opening malnologue they sang
they wrapped however the song
immediately received backlash online
from viewers who branded it as painful
to watch Berlin said um the trolling is
incredibly unfair to be frank quote we
wanted to open the show with some energy
some fun and also lay out straight away
that this was hopefully going to feel
like a different night but with a
familiarity as well and what Ariana did
was exactly that I think a lot of people
don't like change and there's a view
that the baftas have to be this slightly
stiff traditional British middle England
messaging but American Awards shows have
much more Razzmatazz much more show Biz
and perhaps a broader range of people
being involved we were not we felt we're
not about Revolution we're about
Evolution oh I didn't even realize that
like that was their way of competing
with America okay better like next year
baftas
um but I kind of like hated how he
opened his statement with just being
like Ariana and her team did it all it's
like sir like he just wanted to wash his
hands of it like I didn't do this you're
the like you had to approve it like you
are in charge of the show so like you
bear responsibilities as well you can't
just like dump it all on Ariana okay
like [__] off I did not like that
um and now learning that like them
opening with like a that was like their
way of LARPing As Americans like now
I've like now I hate it even more no and
they're like trying to tell us that we
didn't like it because it wasn't British
enough I'm watching this like as an
American with American Standards yeah
it's not it and I actually felt like the
audience was really
um kind you know ever receptive smiling
clapping
I don't feel like they they were against
it because it was British I think they
were against it because like it wasn't
really amazing and I think when you want
to do something like that like it has to
be amazing or else it's just kind of a
flop
yeah and I also think using the term
backlash is like a little strong here
it's not backlash people aren't you know
calling for her to be you know removed
from all of her future films there for
the I would say 99.9 of the [__] I've
seen is like funny playful meme culture
yeah it's pretty harmless I don't think
Ariana should feel bad she didn't do
anything wrong you know she put herself
out there and it didn't work out yeah
she deactivated her Twitter by the way
so I don't know I'm taking this well I
know and it's like part of me is like
yeah people are so mean but also part of
me is like this is par for the course
when you become a major major star and I
feel like it happened really fast for
Ariana Dubose like last year was kind of
her first year on the scene I know she's
been like working for many years but you
know she did the award show circuit last
year now she's like a part of it
um and being poked fun at in like in a
really kind of harmless way is the
culture
um and I feel sad that she deactivated
her Twitter I think more often than not
like you're gonna win over the public by
like getting in on the fun Lea Michelle
um
so this just kind of went sideways in
every single way possible yeah I don't
think anyone ever expected that even if
it wasn't good that there would just be
this much
Harmony in how
bad it was you know like yeah that and
that even like that A Moment Like This
would go viral when it's just like kind
of random and it could have just been
like oh that was weird and we all move
on but like the weird [__] happens all
the time yeah like because it's not like
it was a train wreck it was just it's
not like she fell on her face right like
it was just not perfect no just
conceptually like the whole concept was
weird it was poorly executed
um it was cringe like the dance moves
and other people's reactions because
every time their name was said we saw
their face like they felt weird too it
was like a collective weird moment for
us all to experience yeah yes it was and
also like that we say this all the time
like hosting or she wasn't the worst job
it's a thankless job every single person
who does it who's responsible for a
monologue or whatever like gets roasted
yep
like yeah
so um I hope she is able to make life
come back and and be okay like because I
don't think it's like anything that bad
a time it's just it's just it's not your
way it didn't go her way if I could
speak to Ariana I would just like remind
her it's not that deep like you don't do
anything bad or wrong like it's just
like a little embarrassing but like a
great way to bounce back from something
like this is always to get in on the fun
like she should recreate The Tick Tock
like you know and use the voice over and
do the dance like get in on the fun
that's how you come out on top of
situations like this when you like take
it so serious and you like hide
it it's not a good way to handle PR
things like this just take her power
back she needs to do the shoulder dance
move that's going viral Angela Bassett
did the thing that's what she needs to
do like get in on the fun girlfriend
it's not that deep no it's not that deep
but um the Baptist did take place this
weekend William and Kate were in
attendance yeah being like a really
[__] cute and yeah I know she talks
to us she tapses but they were very
chummy for them yeah for them I mean the
back does I feel like is like a
glamorous kind of less Royal more
relaxed environment they looked
beautiful everyone was you know defying
over Kate our environmental you know
Queen not gonna waste a single resource
wearing earrings from Zara and a dress
she wore many years ago that she had
like re-purposed a seamstress came in
out of the little Cape they modernized
it more with the times more on Trend she
wore the black gloves she looked
beautiful they looked great they never
really step out in non-royal events that
are like more pop culturally I think
it's maybe once or twice a year yeah and
it was fabulous to see it I loved it
yeah they hadn't been to the Baptist
since before covid and we needed that
from them
they needed that too even though they
just gave us those moments in Boston
yeah no they've kind of been doing it a
lot they also weirdly went to um a while
ago but it was like this year well last
year James no the other one um Top Gun
they did a Top Gun
Premiere like an international one yeah
and who was it that met was it Miles
Teller who was like so excited to meet
him they I think they all were yeah and
they did James they go to James Bond
Premiere yeah
they're killing it I think they've like
really realized how they need to step up
their game in terms of like pop culture
moments on a global scale because like
they're you know there's this machine
against them now Harry I mean Harry and
Megan yeah excuse me
um and they've like just pretty much
like not fought back and that's the
Royal way but I think they're them
stepping out like hobnobbing with
glamorous people very the same people
that like Harry and Megan are up like in
that circle now like the Hollywood
Elites
um
I think it's their way of like entering
the conversation yeah but they also
can't be seen to do too much of that
because then it starts to like be weird
they'll start going to like you know the
opening of an envelope so I think right
now the amount that they're doing is
really perfect they're giving us a lot
of moments but it doesn't feel not Royal
agreed it doesn't feel like common
common oh yikes yes
um the Baptists looked lovely you know a
lot of uh
a-listers really showing up and showing
out I think that's like a really well
respected award risk if you're like an
artist actor
um and it's spread some rumors I it's
from dumois so like again you have to
take everything with half a grain of
salt but there are rumors that Lily
James who was you know the Baptist girly
she was at all the After parties and
Matt Smith have gotten back together I
didn't even really like know that she
had dated him until I became obsessed
with him as Damon from uh House of the
Dragon but apparently they were together
for many many years and there are rumors
circulating that they've started to date
again which is like so baftas you know
it's like so British I love that for
them I hope it's true me too
like I like I will like if if there is a
ship to have be had like I will I will
get on like I'll do the manual labor in
building it like I will
I will go to Home Depot if you build it
they will come turdy right that's that's
what we're doing we're building it okay
well speaking of ships and maybe new
relationships our next story Avril
Lavigne is seen hugging it out with Tyga
after dinner at Nobu Avril Lavigne and
Tyga have been getting really
comfortable around each other evidence
to new picks after they shared a meal at
one of LA's most famous celeb hot spots
Tyga Avril and a few others grab dinner
at Nobu Sunday night where we're told
they seem to be hitting it off the two
hugged it out after dinner in the
parking lot as if to say goodbye but
then left together in the same car hmm
we've spoken to you maybe they live in
the same area TMZ spoke to sources close
to both Avril and tiger who say they've
been hanging out together a lot lately
though it's unclear if things are
romantic
this is I mean this is so [__] random
yeah okay if you had to bet do you think
it's romantic or just like they have
mutual friends they were at a group
dinner and they should it's important to
note it was a group dinner and that
changes everything but I also feel like
when you're a celebrity one they like to
like bring their people with them yeah
two they like to like buffer engagements
you know
because it's like kind of in a mature
thing I feel like you know yes
um
so and they were at Nobu so maybe like
they knew they would be spotted but I do
feel like sometimes people go to Nobu
even though they know they're going to
get spotted it's like it's a great meal
I don't care yeah I mean that both of
their reps responding to TMZ and saying
they've been hanging out like this whole
thing gives like a little bit of like a
thirsty moment they spoke to sources
close so it's not like reps putting out
okay okay okay thank you for that's
that's very different okay
um
I would say yeah like I would say
they're like giving it a shot you know
yeah
like when I look at who Tyga has dated
in the past Avril would not fall into
the category of his type and when I look
at who Avril has dated in the past Tyga
wouldn't fall into the category of her
type either she's like very like rocker
yeah and he's and he's very like you
know Instagram model yeah
so I don't know maybe they're going into
business together maybe I feel like they
could be
chit chatting
I mean it's just so Random that's why
I'm like having a hard time seeing it
like these are two people I would have
thought probably don't even know each
other like I don't even know each
other's names her like she her type is
always different like she was engaged to
Mad son she was dating birdie Jenner
forever like the two of them had nothing
in common yeah I think she likes
musicians yeah I could see it like I
wouldn't have predicted it like you know
I guess I could see it yeah it's just an
odd pairing to people from like in my in
my mind like two different ends of the
Earth yeah
like
I don't know those are kind of my
favorite couples
yeah that's true it's always the
unexpected ones yeah and I feel like
when they have enough
not in common it's a good recipe it's
you know it's not too close or Comfort
like Kelsey and Morgan Evans like yeah
you do your punk rock thing you do your
rap thing and like I'll see you for
dinner and we'll meet we'll meet at home
and you'll tell me about what's going on
in your business because I have no
[__] clue yeah yeah no you're right
about that like it they always say
opposites attract so I guess we'll have
to wait and see this might just be like
a one-time thing that we like never hear
about again
yeah I could see that it being a
one-time thing that we literally never
hear why are you laughing and then like
I could see us in a few years being like
Oh remember when Tyga and ever was
probably together and we'll be like that
never happened yeah yeah no totally I
mean I'll forget about this if I never
hear about this again like I will forget
about this yeah
it's still random but you know what like
if
if there's a relationship there like I'm
open to exploring
yeah I'm trying to see what she's
wearing if it's like a date outfit good
question it's an oversized hoodie as a
dress but her hair she's like she's like
rocker chick you know like they don't
believe in the Glam yeah no she looks
cool could be a date could be a date
yeah like her wearing a hoodie as a
dress is like you know uh you wearing a
pantsuit like it's it's fancy for you
you know
yeah sure she's not like other girls no
she's not so
he drove and she's in the passenger seat
and I heard that Angela Bassett did the
thing I heard that too Viola Davis my
woman King
it's actually like the more I hear it
the more I'm actually impressed by the
lyricism Yeah rhyming thing and King
genius
Dr Seuss could never
said my woman King I can't stop like
Pharrell yeah
no you guys have to watch it for
yourself it's just it's all over Tick
Tock just search like Ariana Dubose
search Viola Davis search angelabasa if
it wasn't going viral and I wasn't
seeing the clip over and over again like
and I just saw it once when I was
watching the bathrooms live like I
really wouldn't have thought about it
again which is why it's so it just like
sticks with you because it's like you
keep seeing it like everybody had the
same thought yeah like this is weird
this is odd
just a little chaotic
just a little chaotic a little too much
chaos
amen and the more you watch it you like
discover new things about it it's very
exciting yeah especially it's not like
if you watch a performance as a whole
like the song This song is that it's
sandwiched between you know because
there's like a lot and if you watch a
performance as a whole and like every
time you watch it you focus on a
different audience member's reaction I
mean you could be there for hours yeah
yeah it should be studied no someone
wrote a really funny tweet like I want
to spend 12 hours studying every
audience
um member and put together a
presentation there'll be one hour as to
why she didn't just say Cate Blanchette
Blanchette Kate why did you like why
those lyrics I don't know because it's
not like it needed to rhyme right at the
beginning syllables
Blanchette Kate I'm obsessed Ariana
Dubose like literally for president I
love her like it takes such balls to get
up there and like just do any type of
performance in front of that crowd but
to do such a like a bad performance
honestly you have my unwavering respect
but I just want to say like I do like
the idea I feel like over the years
people have done like a musical
monologue Kelly Kelly
I saw um someone posted a clip of Aubrey
Plaza hosting like the independent film
critics award like she did like a little
Cabaret something I've seen it uh and
they said like this is what Ariana
dibose was trying to do and I watched it
I enjoyed it it wasn't even like amazing
but it was just good and she made funny
jokes and it was good like whatever
um I think Hugh Jackman did one once
like I love the concept yeah but it's
Gotta Be Sharp
the execute it's all in the execution
yeah
and this one fell flat but I'm enjoying
it I'm enjoying it too and I just hope
that she's okay because it's not that
serious and I know I don't want her to
like
you know be like depressed yeah yeah
um our next story hoping to for some
good execution because My Big Fat Greek
Wedding three
gets a September premiere date and a
first cast photo obsessed and the cast
photo by the way look at the background
where do they look like they are they're
in Greece Greek the porticolas family is
back focus feature chair the First cast
photo from the upcoming comedy My Big
Fat Greek Wedding three for which the
cast of the first two films have
reunited announcing the third
installment will Premiere in theaters
worldwide on September 8th oh that's
pretty close like not terrible not
terrible also star Nia vardal vardalos
who plays Tula is directing and writing
the movie as well so
um it's going to be exciting their
daughter Paris yeah is in the movie and
a newcomer Elias cacavas I feel like
that's her boyfriend because he looks to
be her age yeah and I wonder if they're
getting married
you know every every movie has to have a
wedding last year wow and Elias kakov is
like I think is Greek so then she would
be they're going to be married in Greece
yeah and she would be Paris cacavas
because it's funny that her name is
Paris Miller and like she's a part of
this big green she's the daughter of eon
Mueller Ian Miller
um where's the Dad
who said tula's dad I was seen on the
picture he's not in the picture
I'm gonna go look it up
oh my God let me tell you how I'm not
seeing the movie I mean I am obviously
but if the dad like name a greater
character in any film Michael
Constantine passed away August 2021
oh my God I'm so upset
oh my God I'm so upset I'm like I
actually feel like I'm gonna cry
I'm like really emotional because I'm
like on my period but like when I tell
you like
I can't name an actor who's had a bigger
impact on my life like I'm being dead
serious I'm so upset well if it makes
you feel better he died at 94 from
natural causes oh oh I didn't realize it
was that old yeah
oh the movie will not be the same I am
heartbroken
heartbroken they are no I was I mean I
was just gonna say I I do think the
movie won't be the same without him I
still think it'll still be good
um and I feel like with franchises like
this every time there's a new sequel
like everyone like rolls their eyes but
let me tell you how the second movie was
so [__] funny and so good that I'm
not worried in the slightest about like
another film kind of like you know
ruining the Legacy it is and I feel like
a good amount of time has passed since
number two I mean the time the time
between one and two was so much I think
maybe it was even like 10 years and now
two and three is probably like five but
I feel like we got enough time I
recently just watched both of them like
they're so good I'm so I'm excited I'm
heartbroken to have just learned this
news like for real I'm sorry to have
sprung it on you with such good news
yeah no and I figured you know not with
sequels like this when you have like a
family and there's characters of all
different ages the more movies you make
you know the older characters are not
likely going to be around for all of
them and I figured you know first to go
would be their Grandma who's always
running around thinking she's still in
Greece right um and I'm I believe she
has passed away I just so I was I was
coming to terms with that not the dad
yeah
no I understand
I'm glad John Corbett is showing up and
showing out like our loyal guy one thing
about John Corbett like he's gonna show
up for work he's available to work he
should be in the new Yellowstone
um oh my God that's actually a really
good call do you see the pictures going
around and Aiden smooching yeah spoiler
alert except that I feel like there's a
chance that they put out those pictures
to throw people off from the storyline
because they do that sometimes with sex
in the city yeah no the the way that sex
in the city and what's so great about it
is that they film in the streets of New
York is like everything gets spoiled
it's so annoying but this wasn't a
spoiled fan photo this was a photo that
production put out
I thought it was like a Paparazzi photo
no I thought it was like straight from
the camera no no no I I believe it was
paparazzi photos no yeah when they film
on the street it's like a huge circus
and Paparazzi fans people show up
hold on I've seen so much footage of
like of the moment of them walking in
the street on Tick Tock like just from
passer buyers
oh really well just like that Instagram
like posted like a carousel of them oh
no I'm not subscribing oh that's
different that's different
subscribing to vote so maybe they did
put it out
yeah
and just like that Sparks backlash with
from sex and City Fence we're seriously
not on board out with Carrie getting
back together with big I mean Carrie can
do whatever she wants like Aiden have
some Scruples like not only this [__]
cheat on you once she left you at the
altar like my God she ran away from you
in Abu Dhabi like oh my God no I know
right now oh the other guy had to die I
know and like he's just always the
runner up and I just feel like it also
like invalidates Carrie and Big's
relationship because it's like was she
thinking about Aiden the whole time like
oh he's just like waiting for her Aiden
era yep so such a good call so that's
hurtful and at least he has Tula who
will always love him and always be there
for him okay I forgot what we were
talking about I'm like how do we start
talking about this
um yes John Corbett always shows up for
work I also feel like John Corbett is a
like a really good level of Fame yeah
like he has been working
pretty consistently on like very high
profile probably well-paying gigs but
he's not you know hounded by Paparazzi
he has a really happy stable marriage no
like he's not always like on the late
night shows you know doing the circuit
like thirsting out like he does his
projects he probably does you know the
the right the Press junk it and that's
enough for him dying now yeah and he
also is like married to Bo Derek and
like she has like really historical
famous connections like he is yes did
you watch Shania Twain's documentary no
okay hold on I want to get this thing
right because okay he's like in it it's
familiar that he's married to Bo Derek
but not something I would have been able
to recall wait I'm obsessed I gotta look
at pics
so she was in the Shania documentary
because her
um
one of her ex-men I'm just I'm botching
this story give me a second
Shania Twain not John Cusack what's his
name
John Corbett thank you but they're so
um similar yeah like why is nothing
coming up
so
okay and I'm obsessed Beyond I know
they're really cute they're so cute
okay I don't remember exactly what the
thing was but all I'm saying is like Bo
Derek is like an iconic Hollywood
actress who like deep ties to old
Hollywood so John Corbett runs in
fabulous circles he probably makes a lot
of money he's on huge projects but he
has like a fairly normal life I have to
assume yeah
with him and Bo Derek yeah no it's so
cute they've been together for a long
time agents
age appropriate We Stand John Corbett in
this house and he's in he's in so many
of my favorite hello raising Helen I
know let me even go to his IMDb like
it's our cup runneth over a razor voice
Raise Your Voice
um he's Pastor Dan in raising Helen of
course Aiden from Sex in the City uh
he's really got like good taste to all
the boys I've Loved Before oh the dad
the you know very supportive girl dad
obsessed
um Ramona and Beezus never saw it
uh he's got a really good catalog yeah
he really really does and he's had an
illustrious long career like I'm happy
for him
but in terms of the storyline of like
him
and Carrie I'm not here for but I love
that he always shows up no matter you
know he's you know big on top he's back
in insects in the city and he still
shows up for the Third
that's a stand-up guy still shows up for
the third My Big Fat Greek Wedding yeah
oh my God but I feel like I would love
to know from him like what his favorite
projects are like does he get more
excited about sex in the city being
rebooted or Big Fat Greek Wedding three
you know what add him to the list that's
somebody I would love to have on the
podcast honestly like I don't dream like
I feel like it's actually kind of
attainable I feel like I'm just putting
it out into the universe but as we
literally just stated he doesn't do
dream guests okay
it's a good list we got going yeah it's
random too it's not like what everyone
would think
of course she's actually not on the list
because like that's obvious it's so
obvious yeah yeah yeah people I'd love
to chit chat with yeah I have a lot of
questions for John Corbett yeah and
perhaps he has a lot of answers for
Claudia ashrae perhaps
are you ready for our next story if it's
the next story that's brought to you by
bowl and Branch yes it is turdy
so Bull and branch is making sure we're
staying cozy all winter long do it with
a set of their buttery soft sheets from
Bowling Branch they're made with 100
organic cotton threads they get softer
with every wash so however you're
spending the winter spending the winter
season make sure you're getting your
best sleep with a set of buttery soft
sheets from Bowling Branch so as you
guys know Jackie and I have preached the
good word of bull and Branch for many
years now our entire homes are lathered
in Bowling Branch buttery soft sheets we
both have the signature hemmed sheet
collection from Bowling Branch I have it
in my master bedroom you have it in my
guest room in your bedroom and all the
bedrooms Mitch's room
my room as well
um they come in all different colors we
both have it in white and they also come
in all different bed sizes from Twin up
to California King so they use the
highest quality threads on Earth their
sheets are made sheets are made from
slow grown organic cotton so they have a
superior softness and they give a better
night's sleep they feel buttery to the
touch they are super breathable so
they're perfect for both the cooler and
the warmer months they're loved by
millions of sleepers they're so
luxurious they've been loved by three
U.S presidents and two Peabody
award-winning morning show hosts
they're designed for all sleepers
they're made without toxins they're free
from pesticides from formaldehyde and
other harsh chemicals they fit the
deepest of mattresses and they are
labeled with top and bottom tags so
making your bed is easier than ever make
the most out of bedtime with the bowling
Branch sheets get 15 off your first
order when you use promo code toast at
bowlingbranch.com exclusion Supply
Seaside for details that's bowling
Branch
b-o-l-l-a-n-d branch.com promo code
toast today's episode is also brought to
you by Squarespace
so squarespace's tools are really
everything of the sort everything that
you need if you are getting a website up
and running for your side hustle for
your business you work in e-commerce
um Squarespace is fabulous from websites
and online stores to marketing tools and
analytics Squarespace is the all-in-one
platform to build a beautiful online
presence and run your business so
whatever your business's needs are
um Squarespace has something for you you
don't need to be a software engineer a
website builder to make something really
beautiful on Squarespace it's not
difficult it's really easy to use they
have beautiful templates I have built
websites different blogs over the years
and I have to say Squarespace is a
fabulous experience
um so e-commerce is the place and
Squarespace is the space to sell
anything if you're into e-commerce they
have the tools you need to get your
business off the ground including
e-commerce templates Inventory
management a simple checkout process
secure payments whatever you sell
Squarespace has merchandising features
to make your products look their best
online you can connect your social media
accounts to your website you can get
traffic overviews of your website you
also own your content
um they offer a one-click data
portability so check out squarespace.com
toast for a free trial and when you're
ready to launch use the offer code toast
to save 10 off your first purchase of a
website or a domain again that's
squarespace.com toast for the free trial
and then once you're ready to launch use
the offer code toast to save 10 off your
first purchase of a website or a domain
they will help you from anything
you want to secure you know whatever
website domain you want they can do
everything for you it's so easy check
out squarespace.com toast thank you
turdy you're welcome our next story Alec
Baldwin faces reduced prison sentence
after one of his charges has been
dropped in the Fatal Rush shooting so
Alec Baldwin has got the gun
enhancements charge dropped in the rest
case the Santa Fe District Attorney's
Office announced Monday it's dropping
the gun enhancement charge against Alec
Baldwin a crime that would have carried
a five-year sentence if convicted
however he still faces a charge of
involuntary manslaughter for the
shooting which would carry a lesser
sentence of 18 months if convicted the
gun enhancement charge was also dropped
against the movie's armorer Hannah
Gutierrez read the D.A said in order to
avoid further litigious distractions by
Mr Baldwin and his attorneys the D.A and
the special prosecutor have removed the
firearm enhancement to the involuntary
manslaughter charges in the death of
Helena Hutchins on the rust film set the
prosecution's priority is securing
Justice not secure during billable hours
for Big City attorneys
ooh not like coming for their neck not
the big city attorneys being called out
you know I feel so conflicted about this
Alec Baldwin thing because I really in
my heart don't believe like he obviously
had any bad intentions and I'm sure he
feels bad I just wish he was acting like
publicly with like a little more grace
and a little more remorse like I just
think the way him and Hilaria have been
acting like the last year since this
happened like doing you know side of the
highway interviews being thirsty on
social media kind of ignoring it and I
know for legal reasons of course you
you're limited in what you can say I
just wish you would act with a little
bit more humility and act like somebody
you know who who gives a [__] because I
find it really disrespectful and that's
I I don't really have any strong
opinions on these charges being dropped
I just like I'm kind of I'm kind of I
kind of think he's disgusting like in
his in his demeanor since since the
incident and of course you're limited I
know that in legal cases like this but I
just think he could be acting with a lot
more more grace yeah I think there's a
couple things happening one year limited
and I'm sure he's getting counsel to not
act guilty so that so but he's also like
a weird rude guy yeah you know like even
on his best day before he accidentally
killed someone like I don't know that
you're gonna be like vibing with him yep
um
Hilaria is also a little weird uh yeah
as we see they're actually deeply unwell
as a couple together I think they like
fuel each other
um like he has anger management issues
we've seen over the years like with the
parking lots right like he's
like troubled kind of nuts she's nuts in
her own way I think that they when they
get together and they talk it's us
against the world like so they come up
with a plan that's nothing that you
would ever come up with oh my God you're
so right and you just like can't relate
to his reaction
no I can't plus he's sprinkling the
lawyers who say don't give them anything
so now they're just acting like no but
they are but that's what I'm saying they
are giving people stuff like that side
of the highway TMZ interview like
they're talking about it and they're
being gross like I just I have really
deep rooted hatred for both of these
people yeah
and that's what I'm so I'm biased like
that's what I'm I'm looking at this
story through the lens of like I just I
think they're disgusting
yeah I just I want the justice system to
do its thing I think the D.A here like
clearly wants to see Justice be served I
think the case like means to go to court
we need to know the facts of the
situation because at the end of the day
yes of course this was an accident but
like you don't actually bring
accidentally bring live bullets yeah to
your job where you are a professional
armorer like that's just that is that is
what the remaining question that needs
to be found and I think going to trial
will most likely do that is how the [__]
we're all playing pretend so how the
[__] did a real ass bullet get in in
this like the shop that you go to for
fake bullets wasn't even the shop that
you go to for real there's no
there should be no nothing blurry about
that especially for someone whose job it
is the armorer they are an expert in
this situation yeah
um I agree
I I hope that her family gets some sort
of relief from whatever ends up
happening because this is just it is the
worst story it's just so sad
you literally like she's dead yeah so
the family members are pursuing civil
yes uh settlement settlement so
we shall see yeah but that's separate
yeah separate
um are you ready for our fifth and final
story already the final yeah
um it's a little reality TV drama
because Raquel Levis decided this
weekend to just start some stuff yep she
posted a picture of her and Tom Schwartz
actually at Carousel two photos of them
in front of Schwartz and Sandy's with
the caption
um
wait sorry what was her caption it was
just cuz or something like that just
Emoji peace sign
um which the comments went off on how
disrespectful it was blah blah blah
Katie Maloney commented saying you
really thought you did something here
but these comments eight l-o-l-o-l three
skeleton emojis when something eight can
you explain what that means to the yeah
oh you ate that like you're like damn
like you killed it okay so these
comments ain't in a good way yeah like
they ate her to [__] up got it
um someone responded to Katie saying
girl please we're not being sad over men
with the personality of spray cheese in
2023 no ma'am we are not she said nobody
said LOL spray cheese I'm dead the
amount of times this picture landed in
my inbox I couldn't leave it alone
Desperado that I can imagine like oh my
God
oh my God yeah no I kind of loved her
sticking up for herself
um because with the Raquel and Tom thing
and I'm not caught up on this season so
this is just like my POV from like
knowing the history is while I actually
think they probably make a good couple
um
like after getting divorced from your
wife and like you're just really close
group of friends like I just don't know
why you have to go and date someone in
the group of friends like it's so
disrespectful like after all he did to
Katie like being quite literally the
worst husband who ever walked the Earth
um it doesn't surprise me that this is
what he did but I I feel as though her
feelings are valid I have a lot of
thoughts and as to why he has to date
someone in the group of friends I think
it just speaks to like his innate
laziness like he doesn't want to go on a
date he doesn't want to meet that's too
much effort oh there's a single girl in
the group who actually I think we
probably would get along let's go out
also in the comments so on the show they
haven't gotten together yet Raquel has
been it's been two episodes Raquel has
been going on dates with Peter she just
ended it she just like didn't like him
and then Peter and then no but like Lisa
went up to him and was like this is you
can't be dating your employees still
right and she's much younger than him
yeah and she works on he's a manager
she's a server like Lisa was like this
is in 2012 no right so then like
literally five seconds later at the same
party Raquel and didn't he was like okay
um but Raquel wasn't into him anyways on
the show they haven't gotten together
but in the comments I saw Sheena left to
come and I went to click it to expand at
my but my Instagram was glitching and it
took me just to the whole comment
section so I couldn't find sheena's
comment but it said something to the
effect that
Kate
when the idea came up about Tom and
Raquel I think because of the Coachella
rumors which were just a rumor that was
like not true but Katie said something
like she wouldn't mind if they got
together she said that to Sheena and
then Sheena told that to Raquel and like
it weirdly became like Katie's idea oh
yeah but I think and what from sheena's
comment a little bit that I could read
and understand
Katie said that when she was drunk I
don't know so the way things unfold
we'll find out on the show but I do
think it's like it started as a rumor
where it's like that's not true but
maybe it should be and how would Katie
feel if it were true and I actually
could see like Tom and Raquel really
getting along for a time I don't think
they're meant for each other because
they're both too similar and like
nothing would ever really like get done
happen yeah it happened like yeah
um
but it is interesting and it's crazy
that she posted this picture like why
no she was trying to start stuff and you
know what Katie ate her up and I'm gonna
be team Katie on this one because like
it's it's hard to get divorced when
you're in this like tight-knit kind of
toxic group of friends like and to have
your ex-man who for the most part like
really I know they ended on good terms
at the time but like I can't imagine
Katie like looks back uponly on their
marriage like he was [__] horrible
publicly privately like he was the worst
well in the most recent episode Schwartz
and Sandy's is still not open but
they're having a party for the Daily
Mail like they're renting it out so they
put it they get it open just in time to
do one party they're not like running a
business or anything and Schwartz and
Katie are having a conversation he was
like this place cost me everything like
my family like my money you know and
Katie's just like was it worth it and he
can't say no because that's what he
chose and so he would be like admitting
but like no there's no way that's
[__] worth it him and Sandoval like
are in debt the business is costing them
a thousand dollars a day but that it's
not open right their partner who like
talking [__] about them to Lisa he's
like an older guy and like but they're
worth talking [__] about like they just
think that coming up with cool craft
cocktail ideas is gonna make a business
successful having social media followers
means that like you can open a bar but
they don't know anything about that and
a strip mall in a strip mall oh I don't
even know where it is like located in a
mall and where if like okay I got it I'm
all that strip strip mall
like I would love for someone from LA to
explain like is this even a good
location like would you ever go to this
bar like TomTom pump sir like they are
on the Strip the street in weho Yeah a
hundred percent because Lisa's no dummy
yeah and so TomTom like I mean Schwartz
and Sandy's like looks nice on the
inside but it also looks so expensive
and it's like it's so big it's your
house for this like no but all of the
decor they have like a sound bath in the
bathroom and it's like I'm just coming
here to get a drink like no I know and
that's what it is I don't know why Tom I
know why Tom Sandoval because he's like
a crazy crazy ego test but I don't know
why they couldn't just be happy with the
gift Lisa Vanderpump put on their plates
like they have a successful restaurant
where they literally did nothing yeah
like they're simply the faces of it's
backed by Lisa Lisa has this huge
restaurant Empire like I don't know why
they couldn't just be happy with that
yeah and so the and nobody else got it
people on the show Saucy Jax Katie
nobody else got that [__] no just
because both of their names are Tom Tom
Schwartz never even [__] worked at
Elisa Vanderpump established no he tried
to serve at Pride for pump one year and
had an anxiety attack on the bar and
left yeah
so they got this huge gift just like
dumped in their laps and it wasn't
enough
yeah so it's like kind of sad what
happened between Tom and Katie because
it kind of didn't have to happen that
way and like Tom said I should have fall
for her but then he also said like but
it probably would have just prolonged
the inevitable and like made it even
more painful for Katie like now I think
Katie's thriving like she seems like
she's doing really well she's going on
dates like
she seems better than she did last
season when she was in an unhappy
marriage so yeah that's best for her
also like everyone is kind of single
like her and Lala are just like these
yeah single women but they're also like
serious people so it's not like they're
just like messing around well that's the
thing it's that kitty and Tom were
together for a long time and for a while
I think they were like kids and they
were immature and then like over the
over time like Katie grew up and Tom
never did and he almost didn't have to
again like Katie's out here hustling
putting her life out on the [__] Show
starting businesses starting podcasts
and Tom like doesn't even work at the
restaurant gets his own restaurant like
everything is Jesus like entitled like
right because everything has been handed
to him but I actually think that like
that would have been fine but then to
not not only like to not contribute but
then to take away like I'm mortgaging
our house I'm spending all of our money
on this project that you worked for no
on this project with a person who's so
disrespectful towards you like if
Katie's gonna be like the breadwinner
and the boss in the relationship like
she better get some [__] respect your
spouse and if you can't get that goodbye
you're 100 right no 100 everything you
just said is [__] facts so that it is
what it is anyway and so how was the new
season overall it's good you know for me
it's kind of like when I watch it I
don't feel like oh my God I have to get
on the toast and like share my hot takes
I've got you more like a comfort show I
really just like the they've established
a really good cast there's not really
new people except for James's new
girlfriend which is like so crazy that
he's literally living with some like he
has a new Raquel and it's a replacement
but I'm really proud of Raquel because
it must have been really hard for her to
break up with James and she you know is
has always been like this little like
deer in headlights like yeah but she's
really like
finding herself and like becoming
confident and it's it's really nice to
see and like it must be really hard like
you broke up with your fiance and now
he's with someone else and like you have
to go to all these events and it's just
he's there yeah yeah she's she's
struggling and I could like it I think
she's going through
a hard time reasonably so but she's
remaining strong in her convictions and
I I think that's good I mean we'll see
what happens with her and Tom but so far
I'm like she's kind of the star of the
show right now wow because like she's
going on dates and like it's just like
what's Raquel doing what's her health
thing of this for hezekiel met the new
girlfriend yeah and she's really kind of
I think the bridge of like that old
school because she's like tied to James
but she's really like the New Gen
generation of Vanderpump Rules so I
could they like dropped all that [__]
yeah no I know but she's the only one
who really stuck around because she had
like ties to everyone through James and
so she really kind of feels like the
future of the show which is so crazy
because when she first came on the show
like nobody even noticed any mind like
nobody gave her any respect
um but I think she's holding her own and
of course like I love Lala and we only
get like like lala needs her own show
because of what she's going through like
we only get bits and pieces and it's
also vague like it's not enough you like
so there's the LA Times article that had
come out that's like Randall was running
a casting couch and he was uh run having
assistance like run drugs whatever and
then she's like that's not even the tip
of the iceberg compared to what people
have told me the things that I've heard
the things that he's done I'm like what
are the things what are like you know
and it's just yeah so crazy I mean we
now know I think some of that is what
his ex-wife was saying about the yeah
um alleged children pedophilia
um
but she's just going through it yeah
um I kind of feel the same way about
Jersey like
it's very much like a comfort show
because I I love those characters and I
love the husbands and it's like I I
don't especially at the beginning of the
Season not much has happened that like I
need to get on here and like start my
hot takes but it's just so good and I
think a lot of people are like getting
fatigued by like the Gorga judicii drama
Nami Nami because you know what I've got
fatigue of the draw of the dynamic
between the gorgas and the judicious
where like Teresa would act like an
animal and the gorgas were you know
silent because if they did anything even
remotely you know speaking speaking up
wise they would become you know family
family so I find this exciting because
they're [__] standing up for
themselves and maybe they're not doing
everything in the right way that
everyone wants them to but like I I dig
it like I dig it I am firmly team
Melissa and I think the tide is actually
turning like I've been seeing a lot on
social media people being like team tree
was right all along I'm like what are
you [__] watching because I see this
really delusional really [__] mean
woman and I see Melissa who hate her
love her like you cannot deny how she
has just shut her [__] mouth for five
years and she's a human being still
who's like a mom and has her own [__]
opinions and I'm firmly team Melissa
team and you know Dolores because she's
having like a really big falling out
with Jennifer Dolores is kind of coming
to the Margaret Melissa and like I don't
know if she's gonna stay there but if
that happens like I am obsessed that's
what we always needed every season comes
down to that it's like Dolores in the
middle and it's like a blind spot yeah
to me it's so clear yep her blind spot
is Teresa but what's really interesting
they have two new girls
um I actually really like them both
they're like young and fun and funny
um I can't remember their names one of
them is Rachel and I don't know the
other girl's name I feel like is it
Jackie or Jennifer Jackie or Jennifer
for sure no because there's another
woman who's like a new friend of who's
like this hilarious like Jewish woman
and she's psychotic and she just like
eats the whole time and she's hilarious
that's Jen fessler but what is the new
blonde housewife's name whatever
um but so they're obviously there and
Jackie gold Schneider is demoted and I
don't know if Jackie goldshander like
knows that she's demoted at the time of
filming this but like and I never really
saw her as like a thirsty or desperate
girl but like
I do now like she's
okay so she like start picks a fight
with one of the new girls they're
talking about some drama at the house
like the new girl Rachel is like giving
the download to a group of people about
like what she just saw
and Jackie like stops her in the middle
of the conversation it's like I just
want to let you know like you literally
haven't like looked at me in the eyes
once
and the girl's like
what like she's new this is her first
time meeting the group
and she just like happened to find
herself like in the middle of some tea
so she's going over to tell the rest of
the group and Jackie's like you're just
like totally dismissing me and it's like
oh my God Jack you've stopped like I
feel pain for you like it was so
embarrassing
um like I wanted to die
and so now I'm kind of seeing her
through this new light where I feel like
I've been on this journey with her like
last season I was like kind of riding
for for Jackie like I felt like she was
so grounded and so you know vulnerable
like I just really liked her and now I'm
seeing her in this like thirsty lens I'm
like get out of here like stop it was
really it was painful that anybody
else's like butthole clench but she's
like I'm gonna stop you for a second
like you haven't even like looked me in
the eyes like I'm literally standing
right here we're like yeah we know
you're we're like we know you're
irrelevant and demoted that's why we're
not looking in the eyes get the [__] out
um but as always Margaret's my [__]
queen and I ride for her at dawn and
it's pretty good nothing really major
has happened
um but you and I both are now caught up
on summer house yes and this is the show
where it's like oh my God I told you
like I'm watching it because I have I
have some things to say and I'm shocking
myself with what I'm gonna say so I have
a feeling I know what you're gonna say
because you told me you had this hot
take and I was ready no I don't think
it's a hot take and I went on Twitter
and on weirdly and so this makes me
question myself everybody agrees with
what I'm saying yeah I think I'm gonna
agree with what you're saying too as it
pertains to Lindsay and Carl yeah so I'm
team Lindsay and Carl I want to start
with episode one my takeaway from it
which was that
Maya I think was wrong like I think
Lindsay and Carl are very you know
obsessed with each other and yeah and
dependent on each other and they have
this like really
maybe it's an odd relationship compared
to some of the other relationships in
the house like Amanda and Kyle who like
it was so separate I was looking at
their relationship in episode two is
like really the opposite end of like
Lindsay and Carl where it's like Kyle is
like oh he's running around with that
blonde girl Amanda like they're
literally like sitting playing exactly
until like 1 30 a.m like that would
never be Lindsay and Carlin like I get
that like Lindsay and Carl I feel like
are in a very adult relationship very
quickly because when they are older two
he is sober like their relationship just
got really serious really fast and like
Lindsay is just like very protective and
I feel like last season I didn't like
her because when I would I didn't know
her that well because I never watched
the other Seasons but the vibe I got
from her was just like she was this
overgrown child like running around her
party in the Unicorn outfit just like
yep I don't like I I like I just didn't
like that Vibe and like it was very
weird pick me and you know I'm with
friends with all the guys season she's
just like a very committed girlfriend
and a very serious girlfriend and I
really respect that from her and so when
they were coming from when they were in
L.A coming from Family Feud and she's in
the car with Lindsay and Meyer in the
car and Maya said to Lindsay oh I just
texted Carl and asked him if he wanted
to smoke a joint like to me that's
[__] crazy and not even because of
the sobriety thing but because if I'm in
the car with someone's girlfriend yeah
I'm gonna go through the girlfriend like
not even because I I think you're coming
on to respect yeah it's just like why
are you texting my boyfriend when like
I'm right here like why don't you ask me
if like you and Carl want to smoke a
joint or something like no but also you
can't over underestimate not
underestimate under
you can't even glaze over the sobriety
things sobriety thing is like the huge
thing and that's what Lindsay was really
focused on but I can understand how Maya
was confused because last year they
smoked last summer and he was sober last
summer and now he's a different kind of
sober she didn't know that like it she
didn't even think to ask out a lot of
people are like California sober
whatever but to me the idea that we're
both sitting in a car and you're texting
my boyfriend about making plans like
without me is [__] weird I don't
think my kids are in love with him or
you're coming on to him but I think
that's weird Lindsay said she didn't say
that no and you know what I don't think
I don't think she did say that but the
whole time I was believing Maya but she
was kind of acting nuts on the beach
when she had that conversation with
Lindsay it was a class obviously drunk
yeah she was drunk so don't have a
serious conversation that you've been
putting off for two weeks actually like
six months at this point yeah um it was
like a class in how to lose an argument
like nothing what she was saying was
making any sense she was like well until
that point I don't want to Circle the
Drain on this I'm like well you brought
it up like Lindsay oh she had to Lindsay
would do was sit there sit up until that
point I was like kind of like on my side
and then when Lindsay explained to
herself and she was kind of like calm
and I think she was sober because she's
not drinking as much and Maya had been
drinking all day like Maya did not come
off looking good in that conversation at
all and it just seems to me like
everyone this year was like we're coming
for Lindsay and Carl and it's like where
was that energy last year and the year
before because there have been I have
not been really a Lindsay fan ever I
think I had the same feeling whereas
like she's this kind of overgrown child
and she's just not my type of girl like
kind of pick me
um and I always wish like people would
go harder for her even last year like I
know Sierra was wrong for throwing the
drink but at the the cause of the
argument like Sierra had been right and
so it's like where where has that energy
been now you're when she's when she's
actually grown up and changed and like
she is a committed girlfriend and she's
really different and she's like a mature
girl now we're all coming for her and
you know what I really didn't [__]
like
was the lover boy stuff because
so the second Carl expressed that he
wanted to be more valued he wanted a
bigger role he wanted literally the next
day Amanda and Kyle are not even trying
to pretend like they're being so obvious
they're like oh Carl took off to
California and didn't tell us he always
is doing stuff like this just trying to
like put him down a peg so that when he
does ask for like a row a raise or a
robot to be like well you've been just
kind of like out of you know saying for
the past couple like it was so obvious
what they were doing they had never said
anything like that before yeah about him
also with Maya like I feel like I I the
whole time I was like teetering on you
know what I don't think this is
appropriate like I'm the kind of
girlfriend who I'm just kind of like a
Lindsay like if I'm in a serious
relationship like we're serious like
you're not like hanging out with my
boyfriend on the side of your choice
even though I know I I really have no
belief that you guys are like hooking up
or anything it's just like there's
boundaries like they're just and it's
adult it's adults but then Maya was like
she really used to worry about like she
wants her friendship with Carl back
because they should flash back to last
season they had like a nice friendship
because they're both kind of like the
same energy on the same wavelength but
then Maya sits across the table from
Kyle while Kyle is saying the nastiest
[__] [__] about Carl and Maya who's
his really close friend and wants of
their friendship to be the same that it
was is dugging him on doesn't utter one
word in defense and it didn't even
strike me until Danielle did that and I
was like that's a friend no yeah but
Danielle bothers me so much only because
like she has really coasted on this show
and I feel like there have people been
people who have come and go and she has
made a place for herself on the show
it's just like being a mouthpiece for
Lindsay and Carl now mostly Lindsay and
I find it infuriating like when I could
not help but roll my eyes when she like
interrupted Carl I was like you can't
sit here you were just talking about my
friend like
get another stick okay agreed I don't
know her as just the mouthpiece for
Lindsay and Carl I know her as like
Lindsay's friend and at first when she
said you can't sit here I heard what you
said I was like oh that's like a little
immature but then she was just like
defending Carl she was the only one like
because if someone was talking about
your friend like that and like and
they're not around and they're not
around but also like the damaging things
that he was saying about like what he
did two years ago as an addict and like
holding it over his head like that you
gave him a chance but like what kind of
chance is that if you're just gonna
constantly make him feel bad about it
yeah like someone needed to say that and
if you don't say it then you're not a
true friend to Carl you're an
acquaintance sure whatever we're all
friends but like do I want to be a real
friend like you stand up for someone
when someone is saying such horrible
things about someone who's doing all of
the work like trying to like being
better that has changed his life like
why are you going to bring him back to
that no it was super [__] up I just I
couldn't help but roll my eyes it's like
oh my God here she goes again I know
that was just like your bias towards her
and yes but when she was done I was like
you are a hundred percent you're right
and it just highlighted to me that like
Maya's you know uh missed friendship
with Carl is so such bogus because if
you really cared about him as a friend
you wouldn't have stood for that you
know and then Kyle and Maya were on
watch rep and so I've just kind of
parroting like the same [__] they were
doing during the episode and and Andy
asked like do you feel like it's fair
for you to like bring up references to
what somebody did years ago and someone
who was like since better themselves and
they just like continue to like defend
their poor Behavior and the LA thing and
the coke thing so I feel like they feel
really Justified because like now it's
like when you're a part of the the
bigger group and everyone's kind of
backing away from Carl Lindsay you feel
Justified so they were kind of feeling
like Heroes on watch I was live and I
was like you're skipping bully energy
yeah yeah and I don't think the
audiences the audience is going for it
based on what I saw but that's not what
I base my opinions on at all I'm just
like these are two people who are trying
to better themselves who are in a
serious relationship who are committed
to each other and like of course that's
going to change every other facet of
their lives it's going to change what
their nights look like they're lame now
their relationships with friends
especially the other sex like that just
is how it is especially when you're with
someone that like is not gonna like some
girls like Amanda is they're in a series
they're married she doesn't care and not
every girl is like that sorry yeah no
and then I actually I agree with you in
the second episode I felt found myself
comparing Lindsay and Carl's
relationship to uh Kyle and Amanda's and
there's a lot about Kyle and Amanda's
it's like very unconventional and I
think like a little
um just for my POV like a little bizarre
um and if I think about my relationship
like I'm definitely more like Carl and
Lindsay but I don't find like I don't I
honestly don't even think that they're
boring no not at all day at the beach
all day like to want to go to to bed at
midnight after being at the beach chill
dark isn't crazy no not crazy and
everyone's like sitting around and
especially in the first episode being
like Carl and Lindsay are making it
weird Carla Lindsay this Carl and see
that every time they pan to Carl and
Lindsay they're smiling they're talking
to someone Lindsay's like getting along
with all the new girls I'm like what are
you like I'm sure to be in the house
there was definitely like this tension
because there was like things going on
behind the scenes but I didn't get a bad
attitude from them at all you know what
I want to say because we haven't even
spoken about her uh because she's like
not really Paige and Sierra like not in
the drama right now
um I will say I really do love and I'm
like I find it admirable that they're so
welcoming oh like the new girls always
gravitate towards Paige and Sierra not
Lindsay and Danielle um and now Maya is
like very much a part of that crew Gabby
already is like up there and Sam I feel
like is like kind of like a cool girl
like hangs out with the guys drove out
with that new guy who was in the
military
um but I just find it really I feel like
on reality shows that's like never the
case it's always really hard you're for
summer and I don't think Maya would say
her first summer was really hard I don't
think Sierra would have said it either
like Paige is like really welcoming yeah
she's a girls girl yeah I thought like I
really like that about her yeah but I
feel like they're not exclusionary
towards like new girls whatever but like
they are towards Lindsay honestly and
like even though sometimes it's like
maybe I wouldn't want to like Lindsay's
a lot especially in past Seasons like
the only people who are being excluded
are Carl and Lindsey even though it
seems like they're right now right now
right but like but by the way like in
like Lindsay's not a girls girl that's
why like they all have this girl gang
and Lindsay has not been a part of it
because she's not like into female she's
not one of those girls so like she found
like a hanger on her and Danielle and
she's always been like with the guys
like we sleep in the same bed like yeah
that's just who she's been yeah but I
also think there are girls who are like
say like obviously right now Lindsay's
sharing a room with Carl if she were
single she wouldn't be sharing a room
with like new girls because she's just
not that kind of person but I think
that's okay like yeah I don't know if it
would be for me to share a room with
three other girls honestly if there's no
where I can have by myself like I I
like whenever all the girls sit on
Paige's bed like in their street clothes
I know um and they're all like that
would I couldn't sleep in that bed yeah
like I couldn't put my like I just
couldn't what's the new guy's name Chris
Chris yeah
um actually I like him yeah who's
reminding me in the beginning of like
Alex from last season like who got so
Left Behind
um because he was like mute but I feel
like he has good energy I feel like he
can't get arrested I feel like he likes
likes everyone on a romantic level and
like nobody likes him back
um and when he brought his friend who
Gabby ended up liking and they had that
horrendous conversation astronomy oh my
God she was Sammy lost me gabby lost me
with the rising Moon oh my God right
with someone completely because they're
in cancer because they're a cancer man
and your ex was a cancer man and he did
something bad Claudia I was so and then
like that's why you're single no and
that guy was so cute and by the way I
made the best call what was that guy's
name like jezzer jerez durres thank you
he is I have such a good call you know
who he looks like a grown-up Jackson
Mahomes I
ingrained in my brain like you do oh
couldn't be me he doesn't live Run free
in my mind like he does in yours so I
feel like it's like a start of a really
good season like the dynamic has really
shifted like the Carl and Kyle of it all
and then the Carl and Lindsay of it all
um it's gonna be interesting because it
seems like everyone's ganging up on two
people and I'm like kind of not here for
it yeah whenever everyone's ganging up
on someone like I gravitate towards the
someone but I also in this case just
happen to relate to Lindsay as a
girlfriend like yeah and I have a lot of
respect for her like becoming sober and
changing her whole life and like and she
really cares about it and I think they
get engaged at the end of the summer and
everyone's like whoa It's too fast and
like I just don't think so these two
people have known each other for years
they're older they know what they want
they've been through like a grueling
year together like I think they're so
right for each other they're so in love
they say the nicest things about each
other I don't feel like they're putting
on at no maybe they're I'm really into
like I'm in support of there
two more things one when both when they
were marrying the conversation between
Carl and Lindsay outside about lover boy
and Amanda and Kyle in the kitchen I
felt like both girlfriends were giving
such good advice I thought the same
thing Amanda professional Queen [__]
men Amanda rational Queen Lindsay
rational Queen they're both saying such
nice things like this is your friend
first you need to remember that it's
gonna be hard but it's gonna be okay
like give them benefit of the doubt blah
blah I thought they were both giving
really good advice and the other thing
when Kyle is like you know now that he's
with Lindsay he doesn't work as much and
he's not doing this and he's like yeah
when you go from being single and having
nothing going on except for this job
that maybe helped pull you out of a bad
time to now having a person like your
life you reprioritize your life becomes
different and also to have a person who
sees how hard you work like it gives you
perspective on the situation that you
can't see from the inside the reason why
these two can't communicate is because
like
Carl got into a relationship and changed
for the better where it's like Kyle is
the same guy now as he was the day
before he met Amanda like yeah she
didn't require that of him and it works
for them but like most people grow up
when they get into an adult relationship
Kyle has not you know talking to himself
drinking in the middle of the night by
himself playing games with girls being
his towel falling off like he's the same
guy yeah like Carl has changed and
Lindsay has changed and I think change
it can be a good thing and a lot of the
times it is a good thing and I don't
think that it's bad so I'm So unwatch It
Happens Live they confirm so last week
it had come out that Carl left lover boy
um and Kyle said he actually hasn't been
with the company since November okay
that makes sense given the timeline and
I'm glad also it kind of makes me
realize now the way that Kyle was
talking about Carl when he hired him as
like he was unhirable I'm the only one
he probably got a really big role and
not a lot of money because like Kyle
could get what he needed out of him
because like he's unhirable you know
it's not like he's competing for the
biggest jobs and so now he's put in the
work he's so serious like he's sober
he's also going to bars and doing events
which I don't he shouldn't be they don't
say this but like yes it's in the role
of the VP of sales to like go to the
bars and do events but he's also a
public figure so he's like giving his
face and like a hosting gig at a club or
a bar is a paying gig and he's not
getting paid for stuff like that unless
he has equity in the company which I
imagine that he does Kyle did also say
that um he but when the time when he
left he's Carl was making six figures
that makes sense yeah yeah they had
asked I'm just giving you facts but like
six figures could be anything from right
100 to 900 yeah yeah yeah yeah to nine
nine nine nine nine yeah yeah and
compared to what Kyle makes who knows
but
um so it's actually it's a it's really
it's what I think about the Genesis of
summer house like this great concept
like Hamptons reality show and how they
[__] dropped the ball those first
couple of Seasons it was just like such
bad television and I couldn't believe
they kept it going and I stopped
watching to where it is now like it's so
good yeah it is good but they do have a
little bit of a problem right now where
like the Carl Lindsay stuff is very
interesting but nobody wants to turn up
real like nobody's like there aren't
that many single people the people who
are single are judging men because
they're cancer man even though the
perfect man was right in front of her
like it's not giving that like early
Vanderpump Jersey Shore energy where
it's like we're down for whatever we're
gonna stay out all night I relate to you
know I want to go to bed it doesn't
bother me but I think that there's is
not a lot going on except for Carl and
Lindsay yeah that's true but you know
the they have a really like the audience
loves this cast like I do think the show
performs really well and I I don't think
they're out of place yet like where
Vanderpump Rules was where it was like
you're all too old and it's confusing
what you're doing here yeah yeah
um and they should have had more guys in
the house like what the [__] what the
[__] and if the house can't accommodate
it like get a different house yeah no
them shutting down uh five four out of
nine in the bedrooms not cool no get a
different house get more guys like we
want to see people finding love that's
what yeah I thought that was [__]
weird yeah
um so that's your summer house recap
that is your show Jackie and I will be
back later today remember 5 p.m eastern
time we have our live show on patreon
called freaking Fred make sure to become
a patreon member at patreon.com the
toast thank you so much for listening to
the toast the millennial Morning Show
where we deliver the past five stories
that you need to know everybody through
Friday on YouTube so you're watching
this on YouTube please don't forget to
subscribe and give this video a thumbs
up we're also available podcast Cinema
podcast can be found on Spotify in
Central Public Radio everybodycast box
all the places
we are hope you guys have an amazing day
we'll see you tomorrow for hump day love
you bye love ya bye
bye bye